in today's thank you thursday i want to
thank my league of legends coach
warren now league of legends is a
computer game that i've uh recently
gotten into i've had some some early
success with and am starting a new
venture around it called guandao gaming
and warren is my coach and he coaches me
to get better and so
you may be thinking what is evan doing
getting into video games uh you know i
don't have aspirations to become a
professional player
i don't have eight hours a day to
dedicate towards becoming better and
becoming a pro but what i have found
consistently is when i'm growing and
having fun in an area outside of my
business i find that that always comes
back to help my business in some way so
if you're if you're growing and learning
having fun and doing something that
makes you come alive you bring that
creativity and energy and momentum to
your company and every time i found
myself in a rut or stock or not feeling
the you know the energy or the flow or
the vibe in my business
i find it doesn't often work to just
push through and try to force it where
if i'm doing something else where i am
learning and getting better and being
creative that translates back into my
business and gives me ideas and what i
can do to to grow and so warren's been
coaching me over the past couple weeks
and we get together and he he we do this
online with the google hangout and he
coaches me on how to get better and it's
been great to see the results so i
started off
losing a lot letting my team down not
being a great contributor and over a
couple weeks i've gotten better and i've
improved my skills and i'm growing and
i'm leading my team and i'm i'm getting
a lot of kills and not dying so much and
seeing that growth makes me feel good
gives me energy and momentum and i bring
that to my company and so
warren thank you so much for your your
guidance and your patience
i know i'm not always the easiest
student to to work with just in general
um maybe that's a topic for a different
video but uh warren thank you so much
and then for those of you watching take
time today to thank somebody who's
helped you in your business you know you
you can't do this all alone they're
people who help you who support you who
build you up who make you believe in
yourself so take some time today just to
say thank you it'll make them feel great
it'll make you feel great and it'll add
good karma to the world which will help
your business grow
belief
every week i share inspiring and
motivational stories that really mean
something to me that i hope you'll check
out in my newsletter below
you